اقليم دارفور يقع غرب السودان وينقسم الى
ثلاث ولايات شمال دارفور وغرب دارفور
وجنوب دارفور عرف الاقليم كثيرا من
الصراعات بين الرعاه والمزارعين غذتها
الانتماءات القبليه لكل طرف المنطقه شاهدت
حربا اندلعت في فبراير عام 2003 عندما
اتهمت حركتان مسلحتان الحكومه السودانيه
باضطهاد سكان دارفور من غير العرب ادت حرب
دارفور لمقتل مئات الالاف من المدنيين
واتهم بسببها الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر
حسن البشير بارتكاب اباده جماعيه قبائل
دارفور تنقسم الى مجموعات من القبائل
المستقره وتشكل 75% من السكان والقسم
الباقي من القبائل الرحال لدارفور اهميه
لقوات الردع السريع فاصولها تعود للاقليم
عندما كانت بمسماها القديم تقاتل الحركات
المناهضه للحكومه السابقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات